typically that's not true implementation
work we still stay very high level and
very strategic but I really craved that
hands-on experience I really really
really wanted to be able to build
something on my own something that I can
be proud of I mean to some extent I
think it's right depends also of course
which specific consulting firm you join
but also in the strategy consulting firm
I did work on several projects which
were close very close to impact I mean a
good example I think is always
procurement Consulting and procurement
Consulting really often just work with
the client up until the point where you
really realize certain savings with your
suppliers in direct indirect material so
depends a bit on the type of project but
of course for sure what you will not do
as a consultant is to take operative
responsibility